okay next game I got wide again against
carpoon pretty high rated International
Master just going for some old Indian
side of you for somewhat rare yes okay
maybe try the sums this setup and now
try to use the bishop out side of the
pawn chain maybe on g5 just exchange it
he had this kind of opening um yeah this
looks fine for black certainly didn't
didn't play any critical things here
yeah I'm not quite sure about the plan
somewhat similar to to French structure
and plate the porn with this advanced
porn CM do look somewhat similar yeah
not quite sure what the what I should do
that don't like the position frankly
okay this is surprising that it gives me
this weaknesses okay some what we are
looking but I'd like to transfer this
night to III maybe on b3 it's just doing
nothing only three at least that would
put some pressure on the d5 pawn
I don't think he wants to go Bishop h3
but well let's see yeah that would would
have been a surprise to me because he
has got a space advantage and certainly
should keep keep pieces on so this is
logical to not play Bishop to h3 and
allow me to exchange this Bishop which
frankly isn't a great great piece at
some point I should consider to play f3
to break up this pawn here and maybe get
to d5 but not sure if I should do this
now on should wait a couple of moves it
would be a good a good plan in the end
game but I'm not sure about the middle
game because some it will also very much
Rican square cm yeah
yeah you might hear a bishop chief is an
idea don't think it is too dangerous
yeah well I'm quick on the season so I
should always be able to exchange some
some stuff on the C file to to release
pressure
yeah I need to get rid of more pieces
here
so somewhat uncomfortable
and was quite sure maybe taking with the
Queen was also an option okay it's not
really threatening much I think it just
looks so it looks somewhat dangerous but
I don't think there's real threat here
yeah I'm controlling the C file so i'm
not sure that down something like this
here and and all this exchanges with the
with this doubled pawns this is a huge
issue the air really shouldn't be do
have something no i don't think so
listen to to exchange himself here
y am somewhat behind on the clock as
usual
position should be okay mostly due to
the C file control ya know is maybe
threatening to take on their phone
time warning
yeah it's not very pleasant still
I didn't think this would be too
dangerous but maybe I'm wrong this King
isn't exactly a safe either so now the
second-ranked end and my weak weak back
Ranga sizing issue of course the truck
come to play on b6 the joist chuck chuck
is getting g3 as well yeah this is most
likely lost especially if you take the
time into account but the position most
likely as well so shocked
yeah it was winning am so winning anyway
Chuck Chuck from you white resides yeah
I don't think I should lose this
actually doctor or the compass gifts it
is completely lost him okay then and
this is really fatal and maybe we
capture with the deep bond I cannot
account really yeah its opening of the
thief I'll of course was so what's
exciting it was essential here I don't
know after DM may be okay but um yeah
maybe was some some exact moves here
it's able to i'm able to hold the
balance like e6 or something could be
yeah this is already already close to
Los maybe yeah he's getting he's always
getting to e2 and then combines the the
main threats with them and most likely
will win they have to pause oh yeah yeah
why shouldn't lose this of course I'm
not I'm not significantly I'm not verse
hear something I don't think so
computer for instance gives h3 with the
slide wide advantage yeah yeah I think
so my what shouldn't be worse okay